thank you everyone for joining and i'm
very happy uh yeah to have this
opportunity of presenting at this pi
data global conference so yeah the topic
of today's session is exploring tool for
machine learning
interpretability
here's a brief outline of the talk so
i'll give a brief introduction about
what we want to do today
we're actually going to see all many of
these techniques in a concrete example
so i'm going to describe the data set
then we're going to fit a couple of
models on which we're going to try to
understand how they generate predictions
and how features interact with each
other the the aim of this talk is not to
really focus on the model fitting but
trying to see
a later in the process how i can one can
actually
let's say look into them into how do
they create predictions at the very end
i will leave some reference which i will
then share on on slack and also on
social media if you are interested
so in general we would like to to we
want to understand what our machine
learning algorithms uh do that's very
crucial it's important in order to
understand the limitation and to
understand the scope and and the
potential effect that they can have
so that's why
this topic is becoming very very popular
these days and actually this is a huge
area and where what are going to do
today just just look into the surface of
the problem but before going into this
type of techniques we need to take a
step back and and really emphasize that
what is really important it's really to
understand the data and the problem so
even before fitting an algorithm we must
understand the context of the problem
that we were trying to solve
secondly we need to understand the input
data the sources the biases and the
limitations because that's definitely
going to impact the the
the the way the machine algorithm
outputs predictions and last but not
least i would argue that in spite of the
fact that models are becoming more
complex we need to understand the logic
behind the algorithms for example the
difference between a linear model and a
tree based model
so again
what we are going to do today is to go
to a very specific use case on which we
can see some of these tools for kind of
model dependent and moral agnostic
methods uh
in action so this talk is based on on a
blog post that i wrote so you can follow
all of the code and all of the comments
already online
i just want to mention that yeah this
was motivated by the work of
christoph muller on his very nice book
on interpretable machine learning
actually the data set i took from there
but the model
that we're going to
look into are a little bit different
from that sort of reference i will also
want to mention the book of serge
mercedes which is about the python
implementations
a a remark that i want to mention and i
don't have the the time and it's not of
the scope of the of this talk is that
interpretable machine learning is not
equivalent to causality because these
are slightly different problems and in
the references below i
share some very nice articles about this
subject
okay let's go into uh the concrete use
case so this probably it's a known data
set so what we try to predict here is
the count of rented bikes over time
so this is a glimpse of how our pandas
data frame would look uh
our target variable is the cnt which is
a denotes counts and it's a
integers and positive value
and we have two type of predictors in
this data set so we have seasonality
prediction for example the the year the
month the the week of the
the day of the week we have daily data
this is approximately two years of of
data and we also have temperature uh
humidity and wind speed features which
are more methodological which we can
assume that at prediction time we can
get them from a forecast provider so to
say
so
yeah the objective is to generate
predictions for this time series
so let us take a glimpse into how these
regressors look like so again it's
important to do at least a small eda
before going into the model fit so the
black line denotes the the target
variable and what we can see is that
there's a seasonality pattern that
repeats roughly every year a and there's
a slight trade component so the first
blue curve denotes the
temperature so it seems the temperature
it could be a very good regressor for
explaining the seasonality although they
don't match completely because i mean
they 200 so to say uh
the target variables is a little bit
flat when the temperature peaks a little
bit yeah something that i actually
forgot to mention is that in our data
set we also let me go back we also have
a variable called base since
2011 which is essentially a growing
variable it's a linear trend
okay
yeah so humidity and wind speed although
they don't have a train they could
potentially explain the fluctuations
let's say within
each week
yeah and the day since 2011 is just a
linear trend so it's an artificial
variable which is
it could be helpful for prediction
and also we have the year variable which
is in this case is nothing else a as a
step function
which could also help us to to to to
predict for example this kind of growth
in the amplitude of the seasonality
this
in this plot we also see how the
seasonal uh features actually work uh so
he employed the distribution of the
count variable
across different type of categories so
for example we see that in general uh we
have summer and fall a higher a count by
count on average than for example uh
some days in the winter well so we
clearly see that on the monthly
seasonality
uh we also have some tax about whether
it's a holiday or not and we have also
have like an indicator on kind of
whether the weather is good uh or not
that good and it seems that when the bad
weather people don't rate rent bikes as
much so we could argue that these
features are relevant and maybe it's a
little bit
uh
challenging to add them all at the same
time but in just for this exercise i
want to leave them all in the model to
try to see how the model uses this kind
of correlated air predictors
so for this simple exercise we're going
to do a very simple training test split
of our time series so the black line
it's yeah it's going to take like half a
year one year and a half of training
data and we're going to test
a couple of algorithms let's say out of
sample in the
in the in this red line which is the
very last
end of 2012 again it's very important
that we as we are working with time
series we can just not randomly shuffle
the data
so about the modellings that we're going
to have so yeah i've selected two type
of models which represents two type of
different labels one is a linear model a
which is actually taking all of these
features and put it into the linear
regression
but i also added second order polynomial
interactions uh just to make sure that
we might have a
two control for non linear uh kind of
effects but then as i'm having all of
this uh
combinations i also don't want to
overfit so for that i'm running a cross
validation like a time size cross
validation step with a lasso regression
so that i can do certain variable
selection so it's really
a little bit of feature engineering the
second model on the other hand is just a
gradient boost model in this case just
xg boost
uh yeah here you can see the the the
scalar pipelines so
we have we haven't done anything fancy
maybe two comments so for the
categorical levels we
use a one hole encoder for both models
and for the linear models we scale
the numerical values
and what we want to see is how these
models perform and how i try to
understand how they generate predictions
so let us look into the out-of-sample
performance so on the
left-hand side you see the in-sample
performance let's say in the training
data on the right hand side we see the
out-of-sample
predictions so in sample it seems that
the gradient boost model is doing a
little bit better you see that the
distribution of the arrows which are in
the lower part
a little bit shrink in the upper part we
see the true against the predictions but
out of sample actually we could argue
that these models are relatively the
same
we can explicitly look into the out of
sample predictions and again it's we
don't want to fit the best model but at
least they are quite comparable
so what we want to do next is to
understand how these predictions are
made because again these are two
different type of models and whether we
want to try to understand if there are
any type of consistencies or differences
between them
all right so let us start with a model
kind of dependent uh way of looking into
it so without going into anything fancy
if you have a linear model you have
something very explicit to look into
once you fit the model so again for a
linear model it's just a linear
combination of features that are
weighted but what we call the beta
coefficients
so in this table you see
let's say i i rank the the beta
coefficients
uh also in absolute value
a and this is okay because we scale the
variable so i mean the scales will be
somehow comparable
and it's interesting to see that the
most important variable with respect to
this kind of ranking of the beta
coefficients is the interaction between
the month of july and temperature which
actually is negative
so what would expect that or let's say
what we think at first glance that in
july this coefficient might be a
positive but again we need to understand
that the beta coefficients need to be
understood by controlling the other
variables so in spite of the fact that
this is negative notice that the
coefficient for the temperature
uh and for the month of july are
positive and actually quite positive so
what it could be or like
my my anticipation says that even though
that in july
we have
a high temperature maybe one while
controlling for that maybe july actually
has uh uh
is not giving any additional information
and actually could be explaining the
fact that our target variable is rather
flat close to july where the temperature
peaks a bit
so reading these
video coefficients where their
interactions is actually not
straightforward
but it's a good place to start and it's
definitely something which i recommend
looking into it but something that can
give us a little bit more information is
by looking into what we call the weight
effects so the weight effect is nothing
else that's taking the beta coefficients
and multiplying these by the each data
instance
so we can see the distribution of each
feature
across all the complete data set
so for example the the categorical
variables you see that we have a lot of
variables let's say center at zero or
weight effect at zero and then at the
certain value again because this is a
dummy encoding and if you also see the
temperature like ranges across a
like a continuous spectrum of of the
weight effects
uh on the orange
plot
we have just the linear features because
we have many features in this model and
in the
in the
green one we have the the
the features which have a highest video
coefficient which could include
interactions
so if you think about whether a variable
is important notice that for example the
the month of july times temperature
seems to be having the highest beta
coefficient but for
a lot of these data instances this is
actually zero meaning when month is not
july so it is important with respect to
beta coefficient but it's not it's
impactful across all the data set
whether the temperature it's something
that it's kind of always there
so one way of in capturing this
intuition is to take or like look into
the ranking obtained by taking the
absolute value of this weight effect and
then taking the average so in this case
a temperature becomes
quite
important and goes high up in the rank
and then we have the trend component
which is the days since 2011 as the
second one
and so i guess the intuition here is
that like these two variables could
explain a lot of variance by explaining
on the one hand side the seasonality
with the temperature and the trend
component with just this day since 2011
i guess with interaction with with the
year and maybe the going down into the
rank this could explain the
the fluctuations which are not captured
but let's say by this kind of model with
with two variables that we could
potentially fit
actually the weight effects they can
also be interesting to understand
interactions so before going into into
into going into an interaction
example let us go into a specific uh
fault where we have just one feature so
we can here plot the temperature uh
the weight effect as a function of the
temperature
so it's no surprise that this is a
straight line because again this is just
a
the linear component
and the color here denotes the weight
effect so what we are looking into is is
that the
temperature has a positive effect
on average
on the a bike
count so when it's warmer people
probably would like to go
out more when where the temperature is
is actually negative this this actually
affects the prediction into into like
going into negative contribution
uh but then we can do the same game with
two features so here we have the
temperature on the x-axis at humidity on
the y-axis and then we color-code by the
weight effect which is
just adding the contribution of these
two features plus the interaction so
what we could see here for example is
that the weight effect that we have at
prediction time as for example 10
degrees a and humidity 40 it's
comparable to what we could get at 20
degrees but with higher humidity and by
looking into this kind of plot we you
could see how variables interact with
each other so it's even for linear model
this is super super
useful uh moreover we don't need to go
into just the the aggregate future
importance we could but we could
actually with the linear model go very
deep into looking to how predictions are
generated for
a specific data instance so in monarch's
book they take exactly this
284 features so that's the index in the
data frame and here we see the
decomposition of of the prediction and
against the future so for this specific
case
this is a very bad day probably raining
and it was uh
in october
so for this specific uh feature what is
driving the prediction
more it's the
[Music]
indicator variable of the weather
condition this we have all of the
relevant variables in red
and in purple we just have the linear
temps just to compare so it's very very
transparent how linear models
and generate predictions
uh on the other hand existables or three
based models also have a very kind of
clear intuition of what's happening
although disentangling the effect is a
little bit trickier so i don't want to
go into details but this three-based
model have inherited more
measures of importance which roughly
want to encode uh let's say how the
features uh are selected while branching
the sequence of trees so here i have the
rank of some of these
metrics i don't want to go into detail
but it seems that by ranking them a we
see the temperature and the strength
component are also very important for
this model uh and yeah other material
variables like the wind speed humidity
could also contribute
so comparing these two type of of models
uh
can now be a little bit difficult
because on the one hand side we have
beta coefficients and on the other hand
we have this kind of tree uh
like in head metrics so now we want to
go into the direction of model agnostic
method so there are many of them and i
just selected the ones which are maybe a
little bit easier to understand uh
and but again this is a huge field so
the first thing i want to study is what
i call partial dependency plots so the
idea here is to try to understand the
effect of
a specific feature into a target
variable by marginalizing over the whole
data set
so very specifically for a concluded
example if we have a fitted model which
we don't care what it is
but we call it f hat and we want to
compute the effect of let's say
temperature
uh what we could do is for each value of
temperature in this example temperature
equal eight degrees we can take the
average over the whole data set where we
replace the temperature feature with a
fixed value in this state 8. so this
will give us a just a single number and
then i can do this for the grid
of
ranges of temperature of interest
i can do something similar but instead
of hovering over the whole data set i
can do this a
data instance level
so in this case i will get what is
called individual individual conditional
expectation curves so as a side remark
maybe to to to wrap this up
if i take the average of this ice plot i
should get the pdp blocks so let us let
us take a look into how this look for
this specific use case so in these three
plots i show the partial dependency
plots for three features temperature
humidity and wind speed
and
yeah the
the the y axis is it denotes the count
so we want to understand the effect so
the blue line denotes the linear model
and the and the orange line is the tree
based mod
so one first thing that we see is that
for humidity and wind speed there's not
much difference they look pretty similar
but we
see two
different things in that temperature so
the both lines which are the partial
dependency plots look a little bit
interesting so for the linear model
we get a linear relation again saying
that higher temperature implies higher a
bike
counts but the tree model actually
understands that at some point there's a
saturation effect on which temperature
above 25 degrees actually decrease the
number of of bikes and this could also
make sense
um
thinking about uh the data set another
important important difference is the
fact that you would expect
that the
ic plots for the temperature will always
go up let's say with a positive slope
because i guess that's the
beta coefficient that you learn but you
still see this downward
currents which have negative slope what
could this be
well this is actually an effect of the
interaction
so we can capture interaction effects
via these ice plots which are often
hearing when you do the average so
looking into this type of offline this
this could come from the data instances
on which
we have the month of july and the
overall contribution with this very
negative bit coefficient make this go
down
uh
these plots are really helpful into how
to understand the model but they have a
big limitation and is the fact that if
you have higher correlated variables
then these results can be misleading why
well if you look into a how this is
computed
if for example you take temperature
equals to 25 and then you have in your
seasonal variable that the month is
december this is not really
representative of the data distribution
so you're going to test this and
generate these plots with data instances
which are not really relevant or let's
say physically real so bear that in mind
whenever you're working with partial
dependency plots
we can also see
an example in two dimensions so i can i
don't want to go into details
but the only thing that i want to to
remark here is that for wind speed and
humidity these partial dependency curves
in this case are not straight but a
little bit curved and that also the
effect of the interaction effect so you
could see in the in the in the in the
bar in the box below where we have the
beta coefficients that the beta
coefficient of this interaction is the
highest among these two so this you can
also do for for two dimensional plots
another natural measure of importance is
what you call permutation importance and
what we do here is
essentially for each
feature
we shuffle
the data instances and then test the
accuracy once this is shuffled and
what's the intuition behind it well if a
mod if a feature is important for your
model
if i shuffle
the values of that feature the accuracy
must go down
uh whereas if the feature is not that
important
uh and i shuffle the values
uh then it shouldn't change that much so
it's clear that
this is this is quite natural and it's
interesting to see that again the the
trend component and temperature are
always in the top so that that's where
all
these models agree but for example the
seasonality and humidity uh don't rank
the same
i must say that this
measure of importance also suffers from
the fact that
for when you whenever you have the
correlated variables a you might be
testing the accuracy on points which are
not
physically
relevant so to say and so that i often
recommend or like in the literature they
often recommend when presenting results
on partial dependency plots or
permutation importance also present the
corresponding
correlator matrix correlation matrix or
maybe a dendrogram with the with the
correlations because it could happen
that highly correlated variables
actually can kind of split their
importance
and they might look low in the rank
so last but not least i want to talk
about short values which is again a very
huge topic in an area of
where it's a lot of development but it's
a also quite nice uh to understand how
how models generate predictions so i'm
going to give you the recipe is
super fast so to say i know there are
other talks on the subject so maybe you
can look into into
depth
uh but let me go through the through the
idea so the main idea of short values is
to consider features as teams playing a
game where they're competing to increase
the accuracy so to say and what is
important is that we cannot wait all of
teams at the same time if the team at
the same weight so to say if they have
different number of team members
so
shock values actually are it's not a
ranking for features but it can generate
a sharp value for each data instance so
for simplicity let us assume that our a
count model has only three features
temperature humidity and wind speed and
we're going to compute the shaft value
for this specific
data instance and we have 15 60 and 40.
so the first thing that i do is i sample
a coalition meaning a team so it's a
subset of these features and let us
assume that i just take temperature and
humidity
then i i want to generate predictions
with a feeder model this is what i call
subprime and in order to generate
predictions i use my fitted model with
those values but with the
features which are not part of the
coalition i just randomly changed the
value
so wind speed i'll change that to 11.
and let us assume that this prediction
from this model is 4 000.
then a i need to compute certain
combinatorial weight which is just uh
depends on the size of the coalition in
this case two
with regards to the total number of
coalitions possible again this is not
super important it's just a way to make
this competition fair
and once i have this weight which in
this case is
one third
i can fit a linear awaited linear
regression
which the coefficients are going to be
exactly the sharpie values and where's
the linear regression coming from well
we had just generated the data from this
uh kind of recipe so the target variable
is going to be the prediction so in this
case 4 000 i have an intercept and then
i have a indicator function on whether
the
the
feature appear or not in this collision
so in this case i have two
coefficients like five temp and phi
humidity plus an error and if i sample
for many coalitions that this will
generate a data set uh with three
variables or four with the intercept and
i can fit that and
give the
well the coefficient which is in this
case we're going to be fine
so this is how the results look so these
are very nice like the shop package has
a really nice visualization uh
component so we see each kind of the top
features
a
plot and here we see all data instances
so it's really really it's it gives a
relation to the weight effects plus that
i showed you before
the color of the points actually
represent whether this has a positive or
negative impact
with respect to a target variable so for
example for both models
the temperature has a kind of higher
temperature have a
higher
impact on the byte count although for
for the three base model it's a little
bit fuzzy and i think i will see that in
a bit
uh notice that with respect to the
ranking the month of july times
temperature comes quite up
but also temperature so what we're
seeing is that these sharp
plots or like the sharp value importance
is actually taking a little bit from the
bear coefficient and also taking a
little bit from the
from the
weight effects and also uh
the in the three base model we see that
this actually coincides well with the
features obtained by the
the the exhibitors metrics i should say
that the the algorithm that i
explained before is really about let's
say model agnostic but there are
implementations which can speed up the
process again because there are a lot of
computations to be done which are model
dependent they should be very comparable
and that's why i'm tagging that with
linear sharp and threshold which are
variants of this initial uh kernel shot
algorithm that
brief we discussed in this slide
yeah by taking absolute values of the
sharp
values uh we can get like these ranking
plots which i briefly mentioned that
before so i'm going to skip this
but also something interesting is that
we can generate also this type of
feature
specific plots on which we can see
what's the effect of the temperature on
to the sharp values and it's interesting
to see that for the linear model we get
like a straight line and this should be
compared with the weight effect plot
and
the temperature has also this saturation
effect so
again at
temperature higher than 25 the the
effect of of of the temperature of high
temperatures actually hurts the the bike
counts and that explains why in the shop
lots
the color of that of the points like
rock green sorry a blue one
and red are a little bit a kind of mix
whereas in the linear model the gradient
is very very smooth
uh yeah last thing that i want to
comment is that we can actually go with
shaft values at observation level so
this is how kind of this cascade plot or
like waterfall plots look for
observation 284
yeah we also see that the main driver of
this prediction is the weather condition
uh so
so the and it has a
a negative effect i should warn that
this group up it might be that
this could be misinterpreted because
again shift values are not really
looking into the effect of the
prediction but actually on the average
prediction on the whole data set so
my my final recommendation here is that
please take a look into the construction
of the chat value this very nice
documentation because although there are
very powerful tools they can often be
a little bit misleading
when reading these results
yeah
i hope this exercise was fun i am going
to share a lot of this reference where
you can see
all of the of the sources tied to each
of the slides anya thank you very much
that's what's what i wanted to share
with you today
um thank you so much
thank you so much i'm certain um
everyone has learnt more about our
exploring tools for
uh interpretable machine learning we
have a question here from ian in as uh
which is most useful
yeah actually i would i think this
exercise of looking how predictions are
generated it should be kind of essential
in the in the machine learning life
cycle project so
i think you should see all of them
actually they are not hard to implement
there are many libraries which just make
the like use affiliate algorithm and
generate these plots for you
so i would say let's say more like a
detective try to look hints and each
type of approach has its own limitations
but also gives you a little bit of
information so if you have something
which is more independent i will
definitely go there i mean for linear
models definitely looking to the weight
effects and the beta coefficients uh if
you have more complex models also
sharp values could be could be a very
nice solution and again this is a huge
field and this is just
like a subset of methods that are out
there
all right thank you so much one and here
we have a comment from inertio i
actually commented during the
presentation says well the series
patterns are different in train and test
set and it could be expected
yeah i mean this is this i did that on
purpose so to say so the the time split
it's a little bit aggressive but maybe
in reality you will have something that
did you pull a something in production
you do so analysis but it could be that
data is or the model drifts but maybe by
looking into this type of plot and maybe
tracking these values can give you
information about whether your
assumptions on on the modeling phase
actually hold when this thing is still
deployed and i think there was talk
about
interpretable machine learning at scale
which would maybe have touched on on
these points i don't see any more
questions here
just people asking for the slides and
just commenting on the presentation
so
thank you so much
all right thank you bye bye